[Music]
my talk today is called keep the
internet weird and you'll figure out why
a little bit later on my name's Rachel
light I'm a self-taught developer
artists technologist creative coder
cyborg ask me why later Technical
Evangelist at Microsoft nice person I'm
also really bad at descriptors talking
about myself as weird
I'm also oh-ho on Twitter if you're
interested in more things that I have to
say so this is going to be my love
letter to the Internet I'm going to tell
you a story about the things that I've
done the people that I've met and the
things that have led me to be up here on
this stage today we're going to start at
the beginning this right here is the
VTech Socrates it came out in 1988 and
it's technically kind of my first
computer it's a video game device that
was educational it was educational
learning and son you were able to do
math problems interior design and just
decorate houses which is forever ruined
me for playing The Sims that will
actually play the game I just make
things look nice it was it was my first
tangible experience with connecting to
technology and from that on I was pretty
much ruined this thing right here is are
you afraid of the dark
the tale of Orpheus curse and it is a
point-and-click adventure game that was
released in 1994 and what this is is you
just are like doing typical are you
afraid of the dark stuff searching for
mummies and your clues and
I didn't have a computer but I made
friends with people that did just so I
could go over their house and play it
like I was super hooked to anything I
could get my hands on and then I finally
did get my own computer and I turned
into a horrible monster if you know what
this is this is a oh hell it was
released in 1995 and what it is is it's
a where's tool as soon as I got a PC I
was like wow I have knowledge at my
fingertips unfortunately my dad had AOL
so the knowledge was kind of gatekeeper
at my fingertips for whatever was
accessible from the AOL site but once I
got a oh hell I was able to like
manipulate some of the code that was in
the programs and do horrible things like
post links into chat rooms that if
somebody clicked it it would kick them
off their dial-up then from there I went
onto IRC and this was like when I first
really started interacting with people
and I chose this screenshot because it's
the first way that I ever pirated things
on the Internet these are XD CC box if
anybody remembers what those were
basically you know of album would be so
large so you would have to send a
message to a bot that had a bunch of
compressed files that you would download
piece by piece and get it in separate
parts so if your dial-up got
disconnected because your sister picked
up the phone or something you'd be able
to pick right back up and extract it
later so these were like my first
communicating with other people on the
internet saying some of its nice some of
its illegal but but basically I was like
on the Internet and I was like yeah this
is rad I need to do more and then I
discovered geo cities and Angelfire and
my connection with gears to DS and
Angelfire is when I first started making
my own things
I made sites for wrestlers because I was
really into wrestling like WCW wrestling
I made sites for blink-182 because I was
super obsessed with them and they were
really cool I also thought I was like
super Punk so
I had all these cool animated dolls and
stuff and whatever is on those sites is
when I started learning how to program
and I didn't learn how to program
because I was like I want a program it's
going to be so cool I'm going to make a
lot of money I did it out of necessity
because I just wanted my voice to be
heard and I wanted to put myself out
there and then I found web rings so when
I started thinking about my journey and
connections with the Internet I realized
that so much of it was a result of
exploration and discovery and it's
pretty much because I wasn't happy with
the life that I had in rural Florida the
people that were around me I didn't get
along with they didn't have common
interests with me but people on the
internet did and I could find anybody
that was interested in any of the same
things that I was and I could talk to
them and we could exchange ideas and it
was really inspiring it it was a type of
escapism that opens me up to new ideas
and when I started making sites on geo
city as an angel fire I realized how fun
it was to learn and share that
information but then through web brings
in about early 2000 I discovered
personal sites so I saw these networks
of extremely well curated sites
impeccably designed with attention to
detail carefully written entries and
crafted lists of other people to follow
and check out and they weren't just
sites like we have personal sites now
I'm sure we all have personal sites we
all have blogs this is pre WordPress
this is actually a software called gray
matter which was purl and it just saved
all your entries locally but all of
these sites were people that were
helping educate each other and share
knowledge and it wasn't because they
were trying to boost their ego about how
much stuff that they knew or how many
things that they could you know share
out there it was people that were
self-taught and learning how to do their
own design learning how to do their own
scrollable divs and their own link
changes and it was mostly younger women
and
it was really cool and it was really
welcoming that you could be able to find
out how to you know size your font the
best way so that eight pixels or 10
pixels looks the coolest you could learn
how to you know use grunge brushes on
Photoshop which were like the coolest
things ever so I found all these other
teenagers and I knew that I really
wanted to be a part of it
so I still remember the first size that
I came across when I was like cool this
is awesome I found this woman her name
is Melissa
this is glebe calm and she was the first
person that I really found that was like
wow I really like her entries I really
really liked you know the music she
likes all the things that are really
cool also content morning this is
2002-2010
there's there might be some bad things
than all of these entries that you'll
see fair working
I didn't proofread I loved all the other
sites that she hosted a host toasty
relationship is when someone has their
own domain name and they give other
space to other people and then you can
like share and usually it's people that
have similar interests so I could go on
all these other sites and find people
like Melissa who I identified with and
find out the way that they did things
and I wanted to be like Melissa and I
wanted to put my voice out there so I
did this is one of my very first
personal sites my aim'd name was BAM and
Pontius chick because I really loved the
show jackass the site was called ice
road shoes because I thought it was
really cool to take shoes off of crowd
surfers and throw them as far as I could
because I was short and they kicked me
in the head all the time but this is the
first place that I really got to express
myself and you know find out other
information and be able to like dive for
into Lissa explains and find out all the
HTML help that I ever wanted there was
less egos and people were just willing
to help other people out because it
meant new more friends as cool sites to
check out or trade link buttons with I
eventually grew out of having a host e
site and I wanted my own domain name so
I got this one well these two I finally
convinced my parents to let me have some
hosting it was probably one in one or
GoDaddy or something
like that and then I was finally on my
way I got obsessed with grunge brushes
as you can see and I had a lot of domain
names with the things that were inspired
by my favorite lyrics so a lot of the
domain names were like scream oh and
punk band stuff like burn that wish or
car-chase terror though that's like m83
and they're not very Punk it was like
reflective of the internet at the time
with the tiny text the scrollable dim
the live webcam the stat counters which
is the Twitter follower count of how
popular you were in 2001 and I just
started thinking about the environment
at that time and thought how good it
felt to code through discovery and every
time I saw something do be done a new
way I wanted to know how to do it and
asking questions was encouraged and
people really love to help and I knew
that I wasn't the only one so of course
I do the thing that everyone does when
they have an idea on the Internet and I
decided to write a medium sync piece
about it so I put the call out on
Twitter and I was like hey friends did
you have personal domains or were you
writing HTML and CSS not for a job in
the late 90s early 2000s talked to me
about it and they totally did and I
found that like a ton of people have the
same path as me or a little bit
different through MySpace Neopets CSS
for live journal I'm an anime fan site
geo cities other people that know the
good quality of a good run paint brush
everything it was with all
self-discovery I mean I was like cool
all these people similar to me did the
same thing I wonder if they weren't the
same way so I asked were you doing HTML
CSS j/s in the early 2000s where did you
get your coding info from all online for
me it was Lissa explains and dynamic
drive and again the responses were
overwhelming it was all the same stuff
people were using CSS Zen garden web
monkey HTML goodies
this explains dynamic drive and the ever
popular view source which everyone does
that kind of stuff isn't really popular
right now but it was still exploratory
and fun and it made me realize
obviously when community they're nice
more people want to be a part of them
and don't we all want our communities to
be nice because we enjoy the things that
we make hopefully and we want other
people to contribute to that too I would
like to think so
which then led me to think when did
communities stop being nice and I found
a certain trend in the areas that I
thought it might have been and it was
about 2007 and 2008 and it's something
that happened some websites that came
out then it's the gamification of
knowledge sharing and it sucks sure it's
helpful but people aren't necessarily
being helpful because they care about
you and they want to help you they're
helping you because they want points
arbitrary points out on the internet so
I know that people make jQuery jokes a
lot and there's nothing wrong with
jQuery I've written a lot of it it's
great for people that are learning but I
think that people make these types of
jokes myself included directly because
of the reason of the gamification of
sharing we're asking for vanilla
JavaScript answers and we're getting
jQuery answers not because somebody
cares about us or they want to help us
they just want to hear themselves be
heard and while yeah the jQuery saved
solves the same problem it's not
necessarily what we wanted and while
this is a problem I think that we can
fix it what we want is more ideas and
more people is more knowledge sharing so
yeah people are getting involved in
communities means more knowledge sharing
but when you add in the gamification
you're taking away the passion and I
think that's pretty bad we need more
ideas and less echo chambers we need
more people sharing a
yes freely and encouraging code
exploration and let's get gate keeper to
echo chambers so now that we know why
things could have maybe went so horrible
let's let's took a look take a fun
little stroll back between the internet
then and the internet now so I'm going
to give you some cool site how to's for
the early 2000s starting with the
coolest layout techniques slices and
tables has anybody made a website like
this is anybody happy but they never
have to do this ever again okay so if
you're not familiar basically what you
would do is your designer would lay out
your site and Photoshop it's responsive
design didn't exist so it didn't matter
what it looked like and then you would
take this slice tool and you would draw
out all the sections that were important
you could even have rollovers in each of
these little sections so when somebody
moused over they would be able to like
home will turn orange because who needs
the SS we've got images and tables and
so there's a lot of sites that looks
like this at the time and thank goodness
most of that is over the other things
that we did which obviously this is my
site with my cool haircut from 2003 lots
of absolutely positioned divs
it didn't matter because you know we
didn't care about responsive design then
it wasn't really a thing so I could lay
out this whole entire site throw my
grunge brushes all over it and I'm like
okay cool I know where this scrollable
div needs to go and XY zero zero is
obviously the top left and that's not
going to make a difference because no
one's going to resize this div anyway
and so this is probably more popular for
the communities that I frequented then
and a lot of the women making personal
sites would also spend a lot of time
making really elaborate websites so you
would still have the image slicing like
image map techniques because obviously
that really cool font over on the left
side is not any kind of website in 2003
but it was popular and luckily today is
better we have way more things we have
way more cool things that we did that
back then because we have more people
contributing to cool open-source
projects and more people working on
getting specs integrated by browsers so
you know if you're getting started out
you can rely on way better things like
CSS grids if it works in your browser
flexbox tachyons
which i use all the time because i'm
lazy and it's great and it makes things
look good without even having a try and
base CSS so now that we have the layouts
covered we're going to talk about really
cool fancy things fancy things like D
HTML so the application of the HTML was
actually introduced by Microsoft but I
swear that's not like hey I work it's
just a thing and if you may have heard
the term static site before a FAQ site
is just you know being HTML and CSS you
throw some JavaScript in there and it
manipulates dump guess what you've got
the HTML so it was basically a way for
Microsoft with Internet Explorer 4 to be
like look how fancy this is we're so
cool people like ie right and so you
could do some fancy things like cursor
effects so while your mouse and around
in the browser you have this cool star
trail of like plus signs and ASCII
characters or bubbles or stars or
whatever because you're cool and you
want other people to enjoy using your
site so you put stars on there and one
cool thing is this is still on dynamic
drive so you can go back and look at a
little code and I put some of the old
code up here for you to see I'm not
going to like go through it because I
know we're the last talk and I don't
have all day for to tell you about how
we got some cool star effects but I do
have an extremely cool live demo from
2001 so let's check that out really
quick got a fun which way that browser
is
cool all right Oh No
one second cool so here's a really nice
one in case you know you make a site
about some really cool celebrity crush
on and you want people to know how much
you want to kiss them you can put that
cool kissing trail on there here's
another good one of you know maybe it's
winter you want to celebrate the cold
weather you're gonna have some snow
falling and then you know maybe you are
a really big fan of scuba diving so you
want some bubbles to follow up on your
site you could do all of this and more
with dhtml and dynamic drive which was
all copy and paste code snippets and
just ridiculousness so you're in luck
too because not only was today better
for dhtml stuff too we're going to talk
about why and it's because of literally
everything literally everything is
better than what you were able to do in
2001 with JavaScript every single client
framework that like changes the Dom 3jf
of great p5 view a frame you can do BR
in the browser now if you've told me
that in 2005 I would have been like sure
okay I mean you can even control
hardware with JavaScript so it's like
the limits are endless so what we've
made so many steps technology we still
have more work to do the code has
changed but the people have it for the
most part the ways the ways that we
communicate has changed and we have a
lot of work to do to fix the damage at
the gamification of knowledge sharing us
as shaped some of our deaf communities
there's still the same good people
trying to find a way to help out and
create a good sense of community so
support your community is your local
communities your global communities
other communities that you're not a part
of support them all when I started the
journey of writing this talk from the
medium article to being here on this
stage today
I realized something and that's that
never in my life have I felt more
supported than I did in the early 2000s
as I do right now so I went to jf comm
2014 as my first conference ever I
didn't know anybody I didn't know who
Tom Dale was I didn't know who thought
well I knew Paul Irish was sorry Tom but
you know like there was a ton of people
I didn't know who they were
I was just pumped to be there and to
learn and I kept to myself this was me
lurking behind the dunk tank where I
dunked everyone and I learned so much
and honestly like this conference
changed my life I met this friendly guy
and I'm lucky enough to I'm going to get
emotional hopeless he took the time up
to be nice to me and he told me about
Brooklyn jazz and when I got back to New
York I went and I met so many good
people that were friendly to me and nice
to me and they were just like people and
cared and they're people that put people
before code and I think that's important
they inspired me whoa they inspired me
and motivated me that I could do
whatever I wanted as long as I just
tried and that's really important and
you can have that too if you don't have
the communities available to you in your
area make some there are people out
there that are willing to help make
whatever you want to be a welcoming and
inclusive space I trust me reach out to
me we reach out to the organizers there
they're willing to help we'll be more
than happy to give that to you and in
case you don't know here are some
helpful communities there's we all J s
which is a really fantastic organization
that is JavaScript focused and it's
inclusive to everyone and it's just
really helpful and nice and they have a
plaque and a Twitter and they have
conversations and then there's code
newbie which is welcoming for everyone
every
language they have chats every week on
Twitter where you can talk about what
you're learning for programming and get
help and Surin just had her first
conference which was code lands and it
was amazing it was like the most
inclusive event that I've ever been to
in my life and they like applauded
people if they were leaving and I was
like so welcoming and so nice and it
made people feel good about development
there's also your first PR which is made
by Charlotte is on Twitter and it's
basically partnering with organizations
to encourage tagging on your issue issue
cues for things that people might be
able to help out with and others know
together with Ashley Williams started
which has taught people that are from
underrepresented minorities how to
learned how to program node all over the
world and I'm lucky enough that she let
me take control of it and be able to
continue doing that and so I guess the
whole point of keep the internet weird
to me is don't stifle creativity code
exploration is important not being
afraid of trying new things is extremely
important we need to foster growth in
our communities instead of making people
be afraid to be a part of them we need
people to try new things for the sake of
trying them and so keep the internet
weird is pretty much my motto to
motivate me what I'm feeling like I
can't do anything and I have these
stickers so if you want them come bother
me later I have a lot of them I actually
commissioned these from an amazing
designer called bull face because I
wanted some really cool slides and
stickers for you so in case you want to
talk to me after this I'm oh ho on
Twitter my github where I open-source
everything I could possibly be able to
open-source and comment it if I can is
there and then my extremely narcissistic
domain name our Rachel is awesome and
I'm cool online thank you please keep
the internet weird
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]